hey welcome to hot breath I'm Joe Byers
this is Sean Patton this is her weekly
guide to comedy mastery all right you're
already such a such a fun presence
that's why we're here
yeah you bring it out of people Sean
that is not true I think I I think I put
it I think people bury it around me they
bury their yeah I don't think I put I
think I put out I think I have resting
like resting not not [ __ ] a big
thing I think I have resting like boring
face I don't think I come with like I
think I don't come across as a very
interesting guy just by looking at me I
think you look at me oh that guy's
trying real hard cuz he's boring
is this your OCD kicking yeah absolutely
that's exactly convinced I'm the most
boring human being on the planet Earth
even though you're one of the best
comedians I feel like that's the balance
is the rest of the time I'm just the
most boring like I just wanted sometimes
I just want to sit in a room and look at
a wall and not do anything
I just really for hours I wake up in the
morning sometimes it'll be hours before
I actually like I'll sit up like if you
did like you know if you're in a camera
set up in my bedroom and there was like
an elapsed time thing you see me sit up
and then like the Sun would move 2
inches before I got up and left
and that's beautiful I love it you'll
just sit there just sitting there just
like letting it's like I'm almost it's
almost like I'm downloading information
or processor processing things I've
downloaded or I don't know man I
it's I call it brain time uh-huh yeah
where in my in my justification of it is
my brain is relaxing cuz you still do
your 90-minute walks do you still do the
morning like I probably walk more than
90 minutes I'm a verge according to
Fitbit mm-hmm product placement not
sponsored and I wouldn't accept that
because I'm not about corporate funding
just kidding I'm not pleading but uh
actually what's funny and this is not
I'm not the first person to say this if
you wear a Fitbit on stage it like you
see how physical a comedian you are he's
done how many steps it said you were you
walked even though most the time you're
not pacing back and forth on stage
you're you're usually standing you know
in a five-foot radius but you're moving
around and then you get offstage it's
like wow I just walked two miles
according to I remember on a Thursday
you did a big act out and then your
Fitbit went off it's gone off every
night every night it's just like boot
gone off yeah I walk in average seven
miles a day huh and it's the only thing
that keeps me alive just and that's all
exercise is great form in mental clarity
focus well it's also like walking is I
truly think that like it if we just if
every city in America had more of like a
hey walk like encourage the people like
walk places like I've heard stories this
club is about point two miles away it's
a seven minute walk to the hotel
I've heard that comedians they request a
ride Wow yeah but for some people it's
like well I don't want to be seen
walking up it's like you're not you're
not [ __ ] that cool Chappelle even
like how much more cool to be a Fisher
pail and you're what you walk to the
club yeah entourage just smoking
cigarettes and there's people like
walking in front of you and behind you
walk that's it I would be so famous that
I walk everywhere and people just delay
shows and like well no he's gonna walk
from the hotel it's like that's a
45-minute walk it's what he does so he
does and just have a [ __ ] a mini
parade and there there you go
have you had anybody yell anything crazy
at you all these long walks now no I
mean New York you live in New York
everybody walked everywhere LA people
walk a lot I mean I I by making a point
like to me it's like I don't I'm in my
late thirties I don't want the [ __ ]
gout
which people my age are getting and that
sucks I don't want blood clots because
those will kill you I don't know
absolutely nowhere
you will just die you know when it
reaches your heart and one way to
prevent blood clots is movement hmm and
and and I fly so much then that's bad
because you're just sitting there you
know and you're trying it tell you like
stretching your seat but how
[ __ ] who wants to be this guy under
there doing this all flying like I don't
even want to sit next to that person
even I know what they're doing I'm like
god damn it come on yeah you were just
talking before we started about how many
dates you have lined up I do this year
it's it's insane how many dates you hear
here's another water that's pontus water
hot breath hot breath water my breath
ain't so hot after drinking this cool
cool artisanal water
I'm just promised if you want to use
utilities for commercial yeah I do I
travel a lot I'm on the road a lot which
is great and also sometimes exhaust like
I was just I was just doing Vegas hmm
which I mean good [ __ ] God can we just
admit that that place is a horseshit
hellhole and like stop like praising it
like it's like it's so [ __ ] crazy you
go to Vegas and you see it every time
like this group like you know 24-year
old dudes or just like we're [ __ ] very
good like they're the ones who had the
idea before we got here this was a
[ __ ] Christian dump you know and
we're gonna turn it to a [ __ ]
madhouse and it's like everything there
is so stereotypical and lame and just
boring and you go hey Vegas is a year
away from just having a giant
drive-through menu just like let's do
the number three the you know three
nights in the casino and then we go to a
strip club and then one of us sleep for
the stripper and it completely freaks
him out and he leaves earlier than the
rest of us party dedicate our it's like
that every that's actually way less
stereo that I don't think that's
actually ever happened but isn't that
what Vegas is for though just kind of
like a place to put a debauch your eyes
but it's not that crazy like it's
casinos
it's late-night bars and it's you know
strip clubs and there's there's sex
workers yeah and there's you know
high-end gambling situations and there's
but it's not that interesting it's I
give you okay here we go
we're there I saw there was a MMA fight
between Ryan O'Neal and Luis Gomez two
comedians mm-hmm right and they were
doing an MMA fight in [ __ ] Vegas as
something part of jason Ellis he has a
thing Ellis fast look it up anyway so
they fight it's interesting to watch
because two comedians who've been
training for a year it's like for the
first round
there's beating the [ __ ] out of one
another and then the second two rounds
they're just basically tossing scrambled
eggs they're both just out of energy but
it's you know it's interesting to watch
Louis wins anyway we end up at this
after-party in in the hotel room and
there's just a topless woman right and
she's just walking around like serving
drinks and like refreshing your drink
and being flirtatious and then there's
this dude who's like her handler you
would say so you know walking around
with her and she comes she refills her
drink and then she walks off and then he
comes over he's like hey guys I'm just
shame to feel pretty tip you know what I
mean you guys are acting like there's
not a hot beautiful babe with a breasts
hanging out you know you're Vegas I mean
you know I mean live it up a little bit
and that's Vegas in a nutshell for me
Wow is it's like I get it I get it yes
there's a woman her breasts are showing
and I'm supposed to be like whoa dude
but instead I'm a little that's
unnecessary yeah but you but you're
being paid to do this I get it and now
and then this guy's pretending like how
is this not the hottest [ __ ] you've ever
seen it's like because it isn't it's a
topless woman serving drinks it actually
feels way creepier Neal sad oh yeah
exactly and that's Vegas in a [ __ ]
nutshell it's this it's everyone goes
like how is this not the most insane
thing you've ever seen it's like cuz it
isn't cuz you've been telling me about
it for 20 years it's you've hyped it up
too much so it's not that [ __ ] cool
well no II
I was just that just made me think of
last time I was in New York I was
walking by a strip club with some
comedian friends and the guy at the
front just goes hey you want to see some
tits or what dude it's as we were
walking by it was like one of those
comedy Barker's but he's no strip club
the only city in my opinion Atlanta does
have the
Claremont yeah that's an interesting
place yeah Portland Oregon the strip
clubs there are very you wouldn't think
so but very hot very feminist like you
don't feel like like yeah I don't feel
okay
you walk in there all bars like the
Claremont it's just a bar similar
situation it's not there's not lights
everywhere there's not mirrors
everywhere there's not [ __ ] the DJ's
not like Leigh Ellis yeah
get your [ __ ] boners ready it's very
chill and like the women are in control
and they've unionized apparently like
the strippers in Portland get like
health care and [ __ ] you know and like
you go and you feel like you're on their
turf and they're getting naked for you
because they're they like you okay
you're cool enough to come in here and
be be be civil
all right I'll get naked for you but
every other strip club feels like come
on dude [ __ ] low - that [ __ ] weird
you guys out I'm not comfortable you go
there and it's a little more all right
I'm cool you're yeah this is your
decision cool there's some money and
something about that dynamic shift
whereas I guess my point is Vegas feel
this vegas feels like a giant strip club
that you kind of don't want to be at but
you feel like you have to think is
awesome
must have been do a lot of strip clubs
like you closed up in New Orleans yeah
you're the show you closed on Thursday
was on a story of going to a strip club
and I'd be interested like your your
great storyteller and I've heard you
describe storytellers it's almost it's
like a tree house oh no it's like a I
think oh that's wow I can't believe that
told you that one um to me it's okay
good stories like it's like a tree the
the seed is the the the event and in
order for it to grow and the tree is the
story in order for that tree to grow it
has to be planted in truth which is the
earth which we get that but it has to be
rooted in truth but when it grows who
knows where it goes you know who knows
how the branches grow and how many
leaves it has and how tall it actually
is and what kind of tree even is so it's
like when I feel like when you're
telling a story because it could people
ask you like is that true and it's like
absolutely
this happened how I tell it you know the
imagination took that you know what I
mean and I feel like that's important
for storytelling cause I've seen stories
before were you like right and you can
always tell because the if it's like a
tree if a trees not [ __ ] if you don't
plant it in the earth and you plant it
in some [ __ ] some phony you know
pesticide rich oh yeah yeah he's gonna
grow weird and died media yeah yeah that
means you can kind of tell it but you
hear a story that's just kinda like that
was a dumb story probably cuz it wasn't
true well how do you like that the story
you told it's like you go to a strip
club you fall in love with the stripper
and then you get kicked out and that
their review is for crying yeah so okay
that's is that what happened pretty much
ain't for beat so that that that's
actually that is a story that the only
yeah that's I didn't have to doctor that
up at all so I didn't tell it forever to
that's kind of humiliating I didn't
realize that I was [ __ ] moved to tears
by a stripper but also because I was so
[ __ ] wasted but I would take anything
for I never saw her again
they didn't let me back in you know ever
guy was like hey you know you're crying
I was like oh you're you're right I was
like yeah I'll go now I never went back
to that strip club you know but it was
in my hometown it was like I mean I grew
I grew up in there like at a suburb of
New Orleans Slidell Louisiana there's
like the Staten Island of New Orleans
and like this strip club was just there
in the middle of it and then New Orleans
is half an hour away so you know you go
to him and thing man because it's it's a
it's it's such a point of argument
because it's some strip clubs are
[ __ ] [ __ ] holes that treat the
strippers terribly and you can tell when
you walk in it's just it's got a weird
smell to my comedy club right and some
of them are great some of them were they
there they treat them when these women
amazing and they make and some of these
women make you know [ __ ] Bank doing
this and but then there's a weird thing
of like yeah but how did you get just
it's I have a lot of conflicting
thoughts when I go to a strip club so
that's a story you said you pretty much
did beat for beat so like another one
you had was talking about your uber
driver saying would you rather know when
you die or how you die like that
okay here's for example it wasn't an
uber driver the lyft driver okay okay
but lift isn't as popular as uber huh
there's what I'm saying like they don't
lift doesn't exist in Europe for example
or not to my knowledge yet but so when I
tell that joke in Europe it's like well
just say uber they'll understand what
uber is okay and yeah I used to be
against that I used to be so against
like changing details just for the sake
of the region but you realize you're
fighting you're fighting up a hill with
you know with roller skates on that's
just a dumb it's the pointless [ __ ]
battle you know yeah it's like if I say
lift they don't get it cuz they don't
know what lift is and then what then
what then I explain what listens or just
switch it to Ober so how did when that
happened to you he says that and then
are you like okay here's a joke or like
later on you're like oh I remember when
this happened and then you you take it
from hey this happened and then you take
it to like an absurd place you really go
far off this okay what happened was this
we were in we're driving we were in LA
right and like I said we're just I mean
this car was driving and the guy as
we're getting to a stoplight someone
runs the beat like whoo and it wasn't a
close call wasn't even a thing it was
just one of those like someone sped
through when we both kind of like
reacted and I said man close one I'm
glad you weren't in a hurry and he goes
I know man I mean it's crazy out here on
the road and then I don't know where it
just goes I mean think about that would
you rather know how or when I was like
heroin what is like heroin you go and it
was sort of a moment like ah and then we
both laughed about it and it was like ha
ha ha and we didn't really talk to
blocks it was like 2 more blocks in drop
me off that was that so it was way more
civil than I'm making it seen but for
the purpose of the Joker like well what
did he do the guy did ask me if I'd
rather know how I died or when I died
it's really at the essence of what
happened so you strip away all that like
friendly
then it's just like yeah that's what
happened and then I use that as you just
said for a jump to an actual
philosophical debate I've had with
myself before and you take it down the
road of wind and like what if half what
would happen if you knew when you died
and then what would happen if you knew
how you died you compare then contrast
them right I mean I I'm glad you noticed
that I mean I hope people do because
it's performing there does not notice
sometimes you have that though like
that's a thing about comedy that will
drive you [ __ ] insane are sometimes
you can tell an audience is not up for
an adventure
hmm like they don't want to go on a
journey they don't want to have an idea
presented to them that's gonna make them
sort of like do that you know I mean
like then audience doesn't want to do
that sometimes they just want to do this
they just want to agree yeah and no and
have safe you know like like last night
it was an audience the slate show where
it was clearly like they just wanted to
be roasted you can tell and I [ __ ]
hate that you get audiences who come to
comedy shows and they you when you hear
them like let's sit up front and you're
like oh god why it's the same boring
[ __ ] you know it's the same like oh let
me guess you're dating oh how long oh
what's it like who's the dominant one in
the bedroom oh cool is it this amazing
oh wait you've been dating how long cuz
she says it's this long get your facts
together buddy
oh you know who makes more money it's
like the same [ __ ] over ho-oh are
you not dating first date more like last
date right cool where'd you meet tinder
she says you met a lot all the true
miscommunication between males and
females and sometimes people I don't
fault them huh
I don't fault them for that I just feel
like just take a second no wait a second
what's this person have to say and
sometimes you can take your [ __ ]
journey and sometimes like I like to me
I'm not one of these people who comedy
should be funny first and foremost but I
believe it's got to be a unique type of
funny and like to me there's something
more rewarding obviously as a performer
but I think also as an audience member
if someone takes you somewhere you just
don't normally go mm-hmm and then you
laugh through that journey where you're
like man look at this I never thought to
come here haha what a great new
experience I've had that was the when I
first time I saw you live was when the
Atlanta improv was here and man that was
back when you fell in love with the
Israeli yoga instructor oh man back when
you know about that oh yeah she was also
a clown yeah I was a professional clown
you know you did you know I did I tell
you why that we're not no they never
tell you wait when did we talk about
this really we have never talked to each
other until just now know about the UH
the yoga instructor when do we talk
about that we have me and you have what
do you hear about there's another pot
cartons of craft feast yeah what scrap
there's a plug for you [ __ ]
yeah cuz I do so much research over so
many things I forget where they come
from but it was crab feast that okay
that girl
Israeli yoga instructor also a
professional clown yes we had one
weekend of romance and then two weeks
later I came back to Atlanta from
Nashville during what was a blizzard oh
my god here in Atlanta where it snowed
for I don't know I don't I don't know
all I know is when I arrived here by car
there were other cars like pulled over
and just abandoned in the street oh yeah
half the [ __ ] city was shot over what
appeared to be about three inches of
snow part of the plate yeah yeah but the
whole [ __ ] thing was shut down but I
came back to hang out with her and I
gave her a book called clown girl which
is an exceptional novel I I recommend
anyone read it clown girl it's just
about it's basically about that it's
about a young woman who wants to be a
clown and like coming up through the
ranks of the world of professional
clowning and like how it mirrors like
society in general how [ __ ] up it is
for a woman just in general they kind of
navigate but it's such a [ __ ] good
book and
a really good story and I'm actually
surprised it is yet to be made into a
film or TV show maybe they're doing it
right now who knows but I gave her that
book being like hey just this is what
you do kinda and this book is great and
she responded in a very like oh so you
just think I'm just like every clown out
there I'm just I'm just this girl who
clowns to you mister you think my
story's been done before you don't think
I'm original there was like no no no I
think you're projecting things other
people have said to you on to me right
now because this book somehow brought
that out yeah I'm not saying I'm saying
I respect what you're going through
and I think this book is you know that
other people have gone through and read
a book about it it's a good book it's at
the book and she just wouldn't it like a
wall was immediately thrown up oh and
that was it that was the week that was
the end of that did you stay you just
you that was that like as soon as you
met her you're like I got a book it was
like the next morning we like okay I'm
gonna go off a book it was weird
yes that recive but sometimes like I
don't like look especially in the
creative world like some people carry a
lot of baggage into it true because
you're told all your life like that's
stupid why would you do that why
wouldn't you you know I mean for talking
about having dreams is great for a Nike
camping but like it's all so [ __ ]
hard like it's a hard down doing like I
Madden especially her or just any I
imagine just being the easel a Lana Lana
born and bred Israeli girl you know me
getting both sides of that giving me is
pressure from probably or Israeli side
we're family and the southern side of
her family to do anything else but be a
professional clown right you know I mean
and like I'm and this is anyone in the
artistic struggle like you are carrying
baggage into it your parents don't like
it all of your friends are way more
successful and kind of give you [ __ ]
because now you're in your late 20s
early 30s it's like I mean are you still
doing the thing though yeah your comedy
so I'm just saying man I gave you need
you know talk to me if you need I can
hook you up I can hook you up in the HR
department or you know it's like [ __ ] so
you're carrying all this like
baggage and every now and again
something brings it out of here yeah I
know I'm certainly guilty of that I know
I've certainly had I've certainly had
podcasts hmm well like the host is
noodling me about like one specific
thing that I did that I hated that I did
but I did it because you're trying to
climb up the ranks and you look back it
as a mistake but you did it and this is
all this one person wants to talk about
and then I just [ __ ] think you know
16 months of pure frustration like what
yeah so I don't fault anyone but yeah
that was the end of the yeah but anyway
I'm sorry then and lanta improv you talk
about taking a walk we argue that's
that's why that's why I'm such a fan of
your comedy though is because you and
when I saw you at the improv I saw both
shows in 8:00 to 10:30 and both were
completely different and I have no idea
what was improvised and where you were
just taking us on an improvised journey
or where it was material that was all
weaved in and then even to anything on
Thursday again it's like I don't know
what strictly material I don't know what
is material you're weaving in so it's
that's something I mean I'm eight and a
half years in and that's something that
I try to do more and more is blur that
line between what is spontaneous and
what is written yeah so like how have
you been able to develop that skill set
and maybe what percentage of your
headlining sets would you say our
improvised verse written well that's
that's an interesting question I mean I
like I mean personally presentational II
I like to present it like there is no
structure that's works for me cuz that's
how I have the most fun where I what I
don't I and I've learned like you know
if we're doing this if you ask me this
question five years ago I got up on a
high horse and talked about how you know
comedy is all about the unexpected and
all this [ __ ] but I've realized over
time you know it's for me personally
comedy is all about the unexpected I
realize that's not for everyone
so like sometimes you watch a comedian
get onstage and like you could probably
tell anyone who's been doing it or or a
fan of it for long enough can tell when
someone is in script mode
mmm on with that right off
by any means I'm just saying like you
can tell when someone gets up there and
it's just like bop bop-bop-bop they are
firing well-timed beautifully crafted
wonderfully written bits out you and I
killin and they've got it down to a
[ __ ] tee and the sets exactly 45
minutes long right and they have a set
opener and a set closer and if you were
on the show you'd listen and go oh
they're doing the slip-and-slide bit
they're about 30 minutes in you know
like you know and they crush it and
murder it and oftentimes gon be famous
you know because they've got such a
well-honed product right but I can for
me personally I just feel like it it
just doesn't I feel like I'm lying to
the audience if I do that I feel like
I'm not being 100% myself if I get up
there and just do the same [ __ ] thing
yeah I feel that way too yeah and like
that's just me personally I like to get
up there and present it like now like
it's all coming off the top of my head
that's ridiculous to assume that an
audience member would be that naive like
you're just it's like well I mean you
know sure yeah if you want to believe
that thank you but I like to present it
in a way that's like look this is
obviously just me and it's coming at you
however I'm coming at you sometimes I
get out there and I can tell the
audiences you know it's a like it's a
lately last night I miss I'm having him
coming a long time last night
I completely misjudged the late-night
crap I thought the late-night crowd was
gonna be like cuz they were tight as
hell for everyone
so like you know what they need maybe
they just need a little like easing in
so I went up and was very casual at
first and then it was like nope that's
not gonna work and but by the time it
was like it's not gonna work
I had no footage so I spent that entire
late night set just kind of [ __ ]
coasting just trying to like you know I
stayed on my feet I never felt down but
I never was firmly planted right and
that sucks but in that situation I will
usually go harder at the audience you
know m'yha Majan it it's like you're a
your
if if at that point it's like a
fistfight or it's like at that point if
it's like a dance for example it's
capoeira like you've got a ha ha I'm
saying like lo no there's no like we're
not gonna touch we're just kind of
moving and trying to keep away from one
another but at the same time make
contact
um and I think that's different for
every single set I can't treat every
single set the same way I just it's
different people there's a different
mindset there's a different sort of
sometimes and I'm sure you've seen this
and anyone who's been around comedy as
long enough have seen this sometimes the
audience it's not that they don't like
you it's that they're a roomful of
uncomfortable people and they don't like
laughing out loud to them don't shy
about that they don't you know I mean
like sometimes it's an audience you just
like totally something about laughing
out loud making a sound is it on par
with what they like so they're Shire
they're quieter and a lot of comedians
will berate them for that be like what
do you guys not get jokes and the
problem to me when you do that is now
you're making them feel more
self-conscious so then by the time you
get off stage they just don't want to be
in the room at all
so I I'll never bring audience for not
laughing if they're not laughing I just
roll through it like they just died
laughing but then sometimes you get in
front of a crowd that is something just
clicks and they like they get it that
they're part of their part of the show
together and like though they'll never
speak to one another or ever probably
see each other again in that moment they
there's just just like collective
subconscious understanding that they are
a team and they need to come together
and support you
the reason they paid money to be in the
right and those are amazing where they
just did it where they'll they'll take
the journey with you they'll laugh when
they can tell you're having fun
sometimes sometimes they'll just laugh
it's like man look how much fun that
comedians having and then they'll really
listen to the bits and they'll oh and
they'll get all those little parts that
you've all that you've only ever been
the person who's laughed at mm-hmm like
I'm the only person who finds em I'm
gonna say it and then you say it and
there's one time they're like who are
you
just you know that I sustained a head
injury and this is my version of heaven
I'm just trapped in this show forever
yeah but often times it's a mix of the
two and there's always a balance it
seems like there's gonna be a killer
show right I I'm worried when I have it
bombed in a while cuz I'm like oh no
there's one brewing I'm sorry yeah dude
let me put this in your head I do not I
think that is uh that is one oh that's a
myth you think so yes I believe so
I cannot think you have to experience a
bomb every now and again I think good
early on yes but at a certain point it's
it's never like I I guess I used to
think that way I used to always be like
well I guess it was time to bomb no I
think you have to bomb so much anymore
maybe you have to have weird sets maybe
bits don't have to go over that well I
mean last night like I said the late
night show I eat [ __ ] but my fault
entirely
and I don't think it was necessary I
think I could have with a slight tweak
won them over but I didn't I chose a
yeah I could do that but I really want
to do this instead and then when I did
that I was like whoops is it too far
gone would you like that but that was a
choice I made in the moment and I don't
think it was a necessary oak I mean I
learned from that bomb but it is that
way what was the other way you could
hang on this way would have been just
stay with material gotcha this way was
swinging off of it and just be like what
happens and actually I'm gonna say this
for the first time in a decade
someone actually stood up to heckle me
you hear that so much you hear comedians
say that phrase so much up I was doing a
show and this guy stood up and up until
last night I would be like I have never
experienced that ever and I've performed
[ __ ] everywhere I've never once seen
something here's something you can rip
off of later
make a joke ever but last night somebody
that I actually stood up I was just like
I was just explaining to her because I
think you're good man which is one of
those weird
he was talking and I and I was just
finally like wait I'm sorry what are you
saying because I can't hear you because
I have the microphone right and he just
stood up when I was explaining ah you
just said because I think it was weird
aggressive like hey but he stood up to
say it was like in my head I was so
blown away I was like someone finally
stood up to heckle me and you've been
doing like sixteen so I've been doing
stand-up for 17 years okay I've been
only professionally headlining for I
just I'm about to make eight years so
yeah congratulations
well thanks yeah thanks right here in
Atlanta at the punch one of my favorite
cities - Deucalion oh why is that
Atlanta I think is one of the few
actually diverse cities in America hmm
like actually diverse like you will I
feel like when I'm here I see it across
the spectrum of people yeah you see you
see there's white people there's black
people there's agent people there's you
know the people of color sprawl is very
I gotta feel it and I feel like it's you
know a very gay gay friendly city but
it's also interesting because it's the
game to my knowledge Atlanta's the
gayest city in America right here the
thinking's voted that yeah but there's
still people you'll be on stage talking
about a gay situation or just a not
engaged I have a joke about a time I
tried to be gay like what just happened
roughly 13 years ago well like but it's
a joke that like ultimately for me it
was an experience that made me sort of
respect people more right but still you
get these weird sort of like hey like
reactions from people in Atlanta which
is like it this is the gayest city in
America how are you still going like
it's not like this clubs in the [ __ ]
burbs this is what North Atlanta yeah
yeah yeah it's like it's still you so
but you still have that you still have
this like weird Georgia old thing
no Georgia [ __ ] coupled with like
new Hollywood you know so it's like
there's this this city is so [ __ ]
diverse from everything from race to
sexuality to
profession yeah you know and I love that
about it so it'sit's I feel like it's
such a good gauge of like what the rest
of the countries like that's why I still
that's why I'm still based out of here
yeah you can't like on a Tuesday you
can't perform from an all-white audience
then go to like a hood show on the south
side and come up to a hipster bar like
all in the same night and I think
sometimes you get all that in one room
yeah you can get that as I go I did the
1 a.m. show which is one of my favorite
shows in the country great last night
same [ __ ] thing were you like you are
hitting every mark in this room right
now yes you've got everything you've got
the guy in the University of Georgia
polo they're like 23 year old kid who
like probably graduated from University
of Georgia and then went right to work
for the sports program mmm no and he's
there with his buddies like chicken out
comedy and then you've got like the
transgender uh I forgot I forgot her
name but she's also a comedian but like
she's there hanging out her crew and
like they're all laughing a similar bits
you know that like then you've got like
the urban the the the black comedian who
like has never done that room before so
was a little it's kind of weird because
he's so nervous and also so confident
onstage and crushes it and it's just
like it's so much like and you've got
like the the young comedian who's like
newer to Atlanta and she plays guitar
and does like some some comedy songs and
people at first it's like or people into
this and then they really they're like
applauding and standing by the end it's
like god there's so much going on it's
insane yeah I love that
but to your point earlier like that's
why I say I just don't feel you can
perform to me personally in one scripted
fashion and everyone like I just feel
like not that I Taylor or pander myself
just that I know what I want to do on
stage I always answer your question I
always make a setlist okay I always
write a script but I always like carve a
path but I choose to Ernie it
differently every time so like know that
when I'm on stage I know where I'm doing
I know where I'm ending up I know that
I'm gonna start with this bit and I'm
gonna
with this bit and maybe I'll along the
way I'll change it I'll change the order
a little bit or I'll you know maybe I'll
jump over this bit and save this one for
later if it this bit works then I'm
gonna pull pull this out and if this
later bit works they don't bring this
back around but either way I know like
ultimately where I'm doing I just I'm
always gonna choose to get there
differently what's on your set list like
is it just like keywords you write is
that more like here I'll show the camera
I have like the perfect then the like I
have see him focus yeah like right there
I just have did you can see just shows
right just listed and each one of these
if you just went to let's do a good one
there's a cellar you just have like I
mean his words written yeah and yeah the
key words that I know you know somewhat
like on this one specifically it is its
outside with a question mark followed
immediately by an apostrophe then buffet
then condom etiquette then cocaine
confidence then hobo spectrum so like I
know what all of those are right you
know but like rigor those are those are
like that's the order I want that set to
go in is it always gonna go in that
order in the moment I will find out okay
cuz there's there's a dual sided
argument to be out there too because
like the idea of going and getting out
there every single night and doing the
bits in the same order irregardless of
audience there is not Union to be made
that that strengthens the bits and that
you make them adjustable right and like
I yeah for some people yeah for some
people that absolutely works and I
totally get that and [ __ ] yeah that's
your style that's your stop for me I
feel like I get a little more if I for
me I still do the bits I still obviously
am working them out in rooms where I
don't feel like they're gonna work over
but if I can present them my way I feel
like I get more out of it whereas if I
get out there and I'm like I go and I
and I open with a bit hypothetically
speaking
there that setlist I just used and I
start talking about a buffet and I do it
that bit and the audience doesn't
respond then in my I just get a weak
response I'm like [ __ ] all right that
kind of I was using that was gonna lead
into this perfectly and now I have my
doubts mmm that bits gonna work
so I'll sideline it for a second and
then throw something else in there and
if that works then I've got them back
then I can bring back the the bit that I
was gonna do about cocaine that with
more confidence right right and get a
better read on them if that if any of
that makes sense it makes perfect sense
but like yeah so for me it's important
like I know there's a lot of people who
have the idea of set open or set closer
and again I'm taking nothing away from
that but for me personally I feel like
you should get to it it's important and
you're not always gonna do this
obviously but to attempt to make every
single bit I look at them like LEGO
pieces to me I like to be able to build
anything in any order doesn't matter so
I don't want to have a piece that I can
only put here because the world I can
only go there that's clearly right what
if this pitch and go here and you get
built around it that way like that's how
I kind of look at it and in order to do
that you've got a you've got a you know
shape the blocks or if you're if you're
the if you're Lego and you're making
you've got the assembly line of little
plastic but you know you want the mold
to be like oh these blocks all need to
be able to you know but they're not
always gonna be able to do that
sometimes you're forcing it sometimes
you're really and sometimes you got to
build an entire another wing just to fit
that piece but I'm for me the
willingness to do that is what makes
those moments on stage great yeah how
long did that take you to develop
because I'll if that's the best part
about headlining sets is you have time
to breathe and accept order but I'm
absolutely dude yeah you can go too far
and then also laughs - oh yeah I mean oh
yeah lose everything
especially when it's 15 minutes and
you're like whoops I led you down a 12
minute path
I mean look the thing is to like this is
it is so important to know that comedy
is about the performer and whatever you
mind funny is what you do and then and
the problem with a lot of [ __ ]
stand-up now is you hear all these
[ __ ] arguments about what comedy is
and isn't and you know there's there's
people were like now this you know
Nanette isn't funny and it's like well
gives a [ __ ] it's what that person
wanted to do why does it have to affect
you so much that's going to take nothing
away from us yeah maybe it'll yield a
bunch of other than Annette's who cares
to people who watch that we're never
gonna want you if you're really that
[ __ ] concerned mmm-hmm and also vice
versa what if you know you an actor that
swings both way too but maybe someone
who watches that sort of thing a
one-person show maybe they're like this
sucks what else is out there and then
because they saw something that they saw
sucked they see you comedian and hates
that and they're like oh I'm with this
is [ __ ] great to me so now they're a
fan of yours only because they saw that
first right and all the way around
someone who doesn't like your comedy
might like what else is out there and
they find that so it's like everything
feeds everything else but it doesn't
remove I get so [ __ ] annoyed with the
the constant arguments among comedians
that one comedian is actually gonna
shift everything it's not comedy is so
[ __ ] subjective and there's so much
of it out there we were talking about
earlier yeah I'm going to China I'm
going to Malaysia you know why there's
[ __ ] comedy clubs and festivals
english-speaking comedies that big I've
met people I met a bunch of crew a good
a crew of comedians in Edinburgh last
year who are Estonian who've all been
speaking English for about six years
because they want to do stand-up they
learned just for stands just for
standing up English is like the language
of comedy right now also apparently it's
the simplest language to speak according
to everyone who speaks it it's not their
first language the company's booming to
comedies booming so it's like no one
comedian is going to [ __ ] ruin it for
everyone or make it easier for everyone
and it never gets easier that's
something every two
needs to [ __ ] understand it never
gets easier you simply get better at it
you know I mean like the climb never
gets shorter you just get better at
climbing it's all it [ __ ] is man it's
a point being though I came up I'm a
very physical [ __ ] performer and four
years you hear all you hear all the
[ __ ] cool kids all the dip shits in
the back of the room who wanted to sit
back there and [ __ ] on everything else
and oftentimes what they do is they [ __ ]
on physical comedians because to them
that requires nobility yeah you watch
them go on stage and it's the same
[ __ ] three four white guys who just
stand there and tell jokes into a
microphone sometimes with their hand in
their pocket because that's just so
interesting yeah that is so interesting
to watch every [ __ ] comedy scene has
that the same peanut gallery where they
get on stage and the shit's
interchangeable but they have each other
right have each other they make each
other laugh and they [ __ ] on each other
and they and haha oh it's so funny and
no one gives a [ __ ] eventually and they
all end up out of comedy or [ __ ] at
best case scenario a writer on a show
for someone they used to shut up and
don't let those [ __ ] people get in
your head like there is no right or
wrong way to do comedy be funnier dunk
that is actually it if you're up there
and you're not funny that is the wrong
way to do comedy if you're up there and
you're [ __ ] being hilarious and
you're making amazing [ __ ] points
that make people laugh out of dark
twisted [ __ ] that we all experience in
life that's the right way if you're
getting up there and just being a
[ __ ] joint and you're not saying
anything and expecting people to come to
you remember it's making people laugh
making people laugh I'm Thai I hate that
[ __ ] leave the horse to water but I
don't know there's the joke you want to
laugh at it [ __ ] that make the [ __ ]
like make people laugh that's anyway I
get real worked up about this see that's
what this podcast is I know but yeah
point being like they're being funny
there are so many nuances to it and so
many different approaches and so many it
can be done in so many different ways
that whatever is unique to you however
you make people laugh that is what you
[ __ ] do
if it's and if you're physical about it
because what for every [ __ ] who shits
on a physical comedian what they don't
realize is the amount of writing that
goes into being physical as well hmm
it's not just oh that works I'll just do
this all the time it's you you plan the
[ __ ] out you know you're gonna do a spin
move at that exact moment you know
you're gonna [ __ ] you know hawk off
and intimidate a pterodactyl like you
write this into the bit it's part of the
delivery and it requires that effort or
if you're a musical comedian like that's
still [ __ ] hard and sometimes like
writing I've heard people [ __ ] on
musical comedians at the same time they
were that's still a joke they write they
they have an ability to play a guitar
and they know to go back and play that
note right at that exact moment and
emphasize that punchline like it's it's
there's no reason to hate what someone
does because it's different than you and
that's what drives me [ __ ] insane is
when comedians who became comedians
because they were outcasts to begin with
it's why we all ended up in this [ __ ]
world
we didn't fit into a box we didn't fit
into a scene we didn't fit into life in
some way so we had to find our own thing
and our thing became being professional
[ __ ] you know pain strokers being
stroked that pain till it orgasms but we
became [ __ ] professional comedians
and then when you turn and then [ __ ] on
someone else for doing it differently
now it's insane to me because this is
different we did something so different
from everyone else we never know and we
realize how important that is being
yourself and then all of a sudden you
see people like oh that's not comedy
what is that they get up there with a
kazoo yeah it works for what they do why
does it only have to be one person
telling jokes into a microphone like
yeah that works for you but maybe
someone else has found a different way
why do we have to [ __ ] on them anyway
but finding how you're uniquely funny on
stage can take a long time like what was
that process like for you it's hard it's
not you know it's [ __ ] hard it's yeah
definitely difficult I don't think I've
mastered it yeah like I don't think
you're ever done
writing hmm that's all right that's how
I truly believe or even a bit that works
if you record it and put it on an album
put it on special do it on a Conan yeah
okay maybe that's where that that's
where the bid is now recorded that's
you've art you've chosen to archive it
in that form mm-hmm but to me personally
you're never done the journeys never
over like no matter how great you are a
comedy you can always be better able how
were you able to find because it's a
process you've been doing 17 years mmm
I'm eight and a half and I'm just now
finding like oh sometimes when I do
certain facial expressions I get a laugh
or me with a sarcastic tinge seems to
make that joke funny instead of
offensive like yeah is it paying
attention to those little cues like what
kind of tips do you have for comics on
finding how they're uniquely funny I
mean well that's that's that's actually
a very good question because I'd say
ultimately man like it's different for
everyone but yeah like like recording
your sets is important I find just
listening back is you may not know until
you've listened back like oh if I just
if I say today instead of today it just
works better because it's a bit about
the week obviously yeah but not like the
you know I'm talking that's that's a
dumb example but if I or you listen back
and you go like oh [ __ ] man pause uh-huh
that pause [ __ ] just because I paused
waited counted to three in my head and
then said shoo flies you know boom that
just let the uh sometimes it's that
simple sometimes you listen backing you
don't realize like oh the reason this
hasn't been working is because I haven't
been giving the audience enough time to
[ __ ] taking what I just said right
and and so that's important patience is
important and this is something I mean
one of my personally one of my personal
favorite comedians Bill Barr
no I know he's a polarizing figure you
know he's to some people but like I
think I think the guy I [ __ ] love him
cuz he just takes these gigantic you
know he goes for it and he owns it he
doesn't if he says something that's
offensive to some people he will own it
and he will acknowledge that he does not
mean to offend this is just what he
thinks you know you're like he I love
that about him is that he just he will
[ __ ] say something and you're like
whoa someone's gonna [ __ ] head's
gonna explode because of that but then
our that but then he owns it you like
actually he explains it or you're like
you know you are the person he just kind
of [ __ ] on you got a respect that he at
least owned it yeah and something he
said to me once I mean this was years
ago I was at Montreal I was I did a spot
in Tom Green was headlining this show so
I didn't know this but all these
comedians went to the show to see Tom
Green headlong is there like this guy's
doing comedy I got to see what this is
all about mm-hmm but I was booked doing
like a 10-minute spot before him and
burr was there and I had no clue and
then afterwards we're just kind of like
in the back area where everyone's
watching and I look over and I just see
Bill Byrne making a [ __ ] just
steamroll at me and I was and I just
like turn my head back to shows like I'm
gonna accept this he's gonna come over a
couple me sides you know tell me I'm
[ __ ] garbage I'm an embarrassment to
the craft of comedy and I if I walk away
now they'll let me live kind of things
expect ya
he walks up and was just like dude come
here and he's just so complimentary like
sets of just the you know it's it sounds
to braggadocious for me to repeat what
he said but he said a lot of like nice
[ __ ] and then the biggest compliment it
was something that like changed the way
I looked at he's like I can't get over
how comfortable you are with silence and
in the moment I was like oh thanks like
I kind of took it I took it as like a
backhanded compliment but then he was
like no you know what I mean like yeah
yeah sure I played it off like of course
I know what that means thank you Bill ah
then years later we're at to stand in
New York and he was just there doing set
and he said that to someone else they
can't see this [ __ ] guy perform he's
like dude he's discomfort with silence
[ __ ] boggles my mind and then he
explained it more and I didn't realize I
was ever doing this but now it's like oh
man basically like if you get on stage
and you
something and the audience laughter
doesn't laugh there's always gonna be a
moment in every show where there's
silence right there's always gonna be a
whether it's between bits or whether
it's you just told a joke and it bombed
or you just told a joke and it killed
and you're waiting for the laughter to
die down
there's gonna be this moment where
there's silence and what you got to
realize is in that silent moment you
have them right they are waiting for
your next move no matter what just
happened no matter if you just told
something that ate [ __ ] then now they're
waiting anticipating hoping because
nobody wants to see the performer bomb
so in that moment you just told the joke
and it bombed and now they're okay
they're gearing up like let's hope this
next one's funny okay or you just told a
joke that [ __ ] murder and they're
just [ __ ] clapping and you're letting
the applause die down a little bit
because you're gearing up the next
[ __ ] shot they'll be that moment like
and now they're again like okay what's
next but there's a moment that if you
let it happen if you just let it be
[ __ ] natural and in the moment that's
silence every time you let it just
breathe it's that much closer they are
to know it's human moments right I
didn't realize I was ever doing that but
apparently now I pay attention to it now
it's like I will give these moments
there's do I will say something knowing
like okay they're silent right now give
it a second interest hunch line or hit
him with a transition or hit him with
like a new twist or a tag that sometimes
you tell a joke just for the tag
sometimes you tell a joke just to set up
another thing sometimes I say something
because I want them to [ __ ] be quiet
because I want that moment of like
here's the thing I just said and they're
like huh they're listening they're
taking that in and now I know I got
their full attention and there's the
actual [ __ ] joke okay now it's like
it hits some partner because you in that
silence they've given you their
attention and notice that in a comedy
club
if you're ever if the audience is being
rowdy or stupid or loud stop talking for
a second notice how quickly everyone
shuts up and gives you their attention
silence is
powerful in comedy and using it you can
achieve such better reactions and you
can deliver such bigger [ __ ]
punchlines and you can they can read
they'll react so much bigger because
that it's almost like that silence gives
them a more it's like their guard drops
mm and they're a little like whatever
you say next is like just penetrates
deeper and it's important however it's
hard to [ __ ] get comfortable in that
silence yeah that's what an ass yeah it
just takes years of trusting yourself
trusting yourself and oftentimes
trusting yourself you're the it's the
hardest person to trust hmm you know
because especially onstage but yeah man
like is it like remembering to breathe -
instead of like do it instead of saying
something in that moment just take a
breath take a breath and then that'll
cut the pause like you know you're a lot
of times you're so the idea of silence
during a comedy show seems like the
worst possible thing in fact I think
it's the best gauge of how you're
actually doing mmm right killing there's
in my opinion killing and being funny
are two very different things okay
killing it's not that difficult any
skilled talented performer can kill okay
killing is what happens in a room where
everyone experiences something and
they're in there's an enjoyment and
there's laughter and there's applause
but it could come in any actual cost you
know a [ __ ] you put a monkey you pull
off spider monkey on stage with a cigar
that's gonna kill you don't say is that
highbrow well-crafted
joke mashup no killing doesn't always
come from that being funny is hard and
it oftentimes doesn't necessarily mean
something kills right and those are the
moments when someone does a joke and you
feel it in the room you feel this like
tangible like 40% of the audience dies
just like and then the other 60 cent
percent are just sort of like oh what
and they don't
it's not because they don't think it's
funny it's because to them that's maybe
something they've never considered and
now then you gotta process it and maybe
they laugh about it the next day or
maybe to them it's that kind of funny
where it's like wow that's funny and
then 45 minutes later they're at the bar
dying laughing about it or sometimes
it's just I hate to say it but like it's
a they gotta think about it not saying
you know it's too smart for them but
it's something it's something
conceptually or just such a different
idea like that audience member as you
what and then because they went what
they're gonna spend the rest of the show
thinking about it and then they're gonna
have a discussion about it and maybe not
laugh about it for weeks
mmm Steve Martin said in his book it's a
great book to him born standing up yeah
great about how like a lot of times he
felt he was telling jokes that people
weren't laughing at so the next day but
I I get what he means by that
like sometimes humor is such a it's so
out there that it's out there and you
gotta give the audience time to catch up
to you and if they're willing to do that
it could be some of the greatest I mean
but sometimes jokes that are before
their did the phrase before their time
is afraid for a reason yeah that doesn't
necessarily mean here sometimes it just
means [ __ ] in an hour easy to give an
audience that time to really digest with
the joy and maybe to understand it more
and and the point being that like
killing and being funny I think as a
comedian your goal should be being funny
right be funny now if that happens to
lead to killing great but your goal
should never be killing okay killing
okay like it here so here's a metaphor
okay cuz I want to get up there and just
make them pee their pants exactly
instantly and everyone wants that but if
you do that because you were being funny
great okay but if you go out there and
just dumb yourself down and do base
level crowd work and just walk very well
threaded paths onstage and just do very
basic this has already been done by nine
other comedians I'm just putting a
slight twist on it to make it different
and like I know everyone's gonna laugh
at an anti hurt
joke I know everyone's gonna laugh if I
make fun of Trump in this particular
room I know everyone's gonna laugh I
point out how strange online dating is
like yes you'll probably kill but then
you'll be forgotten then that audience
will leave and you go hey what was what
was so great about that
oh they killed it well tell me a thing
it's like you know they did a thing
about how no cuz I'm Korean and my
girlfriend's white and he did a thing
about how our babies you know half sweet
and sweet oh yeah I was kind of dumb the
moment it was just it was in the moment
like be funny sometimes okay wow that
show it was kind of crazy like she told
this joke about like her vagina having a
personality of its own and then like and
that spoke French oh yeah Regina spoke
French anyway that's a dumb example you
don't I mean they remembered what
remembered what happened and ready they
weren't dying laughing in the moment but
now they're like oh man and they're a
fake yes so being funny it's like a
night of drinking okay if you go out
drinking you're and you you hang out
with your friends and you have some
great conversations and you make the you
and the bartender bond and they buy you
some shots and a great song comes on and
more great conversation and you meet
someone you go home and get laid and
you're this amazing night and in the
course of it you happen to get drunk
that's great okay but if you go out
solely just to get [ __ ] up you could
do that that's easy you can get out
there and just pound a bunch of shots
and now you're [ __ ] wasting and now
what now you're eventually gonna go home
pass out and forget that's to me if you
go on stage with the sole purpose of
killing mmm you see I'm saying yes are
you gonna go up and do a very
forgettable thing but if you go on stage
and try and be funny that's like going
out and having that night
well yeah you're having drinks you want
to get drunk but on the way you want to
[ __ ] make a friend you want to have a
great conversation you want the
bartender to remember your name you want
to put an amazing song on the jukebox
that you didn't realize it but everyone
in that bar was like all [ __ ] yeah you
know you want to witness a fight and
get up and make friends with both of
them and then they make friends with
each other and then you end up going
home and banging one of them and you
want that to happen and then also at the
end of it you realize oh man I'm pretty
[ __ ] up that's great you went out and
we're funny and then just happen to kill
because of that mm I mean so that's but
that's me personally I get it some
people don't think that way some people
want to go on stage and just kill it and
just get out there with the with the
very simple very you know of course
economic I get that more power to ya for
me personally I think it's all about the
challenge of actually truly being funny
and letting the kill happen because of
that that's why I was so excited to
interview you because you're you've had
all this success and it all seems it's
been by being uniquely you and just
being authentic all new and like having
your performance is unlike anybody
else's and it does seem freewheeling but
then you'll throw out lines like a
JanSport full of curly fries like it
seems thank you it seems completely just
like a shotgun blast but then when you
listen to your your word usage and how
specific your choices are you're like oh
there's computer like precision going on
here in terms of it's not just
freewheeling he's actually like dialed
in on this moment well thank you yeah I
mean yeah that but then okay if I'm
being completely honest a line like a
JanSport full of curly fries huh my
opinion is so [ __ ] ridiculously silly
that said with any sincerity removes
anything funny about it like it's almost
like you have to just throw that out
there I was like it's a throwaway you
haven't you have to present it that way
it's like guys a JanSport full of curly
fries it's like okay that's an
interesting visual but chill out dude
but if I'm just like a JanSport full of
curly fries and let you picture that on
your own
oh hey why curly fries B why a JanSport
see why would even come in a book bag D
do I get to keep the JanSport e what
kind of JanSport guys have it does they
have a laptop you know pocket in it then
then that all those questions to me are
what makes it funny it's because it
leaves you with this it leaves something
to your imagination
like oh man there's so much to think
about their having phrases like that
does it come down to you like
brainstorming like okay a box of curly
fries okay a satchel of curly fries we
brainstorm like specific words like that
no I I sit down is I try every day if
I'm being realistic with myself it's
about four and a half days a week - five
days a week where I sit down and for at
least an hour just freehand right there
and just get it out and sometimes
oftentimes it's just crap it's just okay
or it's just regurgitating something
I've already written or it's like okay
this is just whatever it's just but then
sometimes it's like aha a JanSport you
know say something sometimes but that's
why I do it I can't I can't I can't
remember the writers name but there's a
writer I can't remember who it was man
but I read about this once that just
struck me is that he got up every day
and after like you know getting up and
taking a dump or whatever you do in the
morning and then have breakfast he would
sit down and he would force himself to
write for one hour not paying attention
to what he was writing and then he would
go run some errands do some day and then
later that evening when he got home then
he would actually sit down and write
like for hours but his whole belief was
that you'd and I guess this is true
subconscious has a lot to do with your
writing you know you figured out you
actually do a lot of writing so
consciously so by getting up every
morning and just writing for the hour he
kind of kicked his subconscious into
gear so that by the time he sat down
hours later to actually work on things
his subconscious had been writing that
whole time
oh yeah you know unfortunately I'm not
his [ __ ] disciplined get up everyday
write for an hour do my [ __ ] and go back
and do it but I try but I feel it's like
it's important like and I believe you me
I know some comedians who don't do that
I know I know a lot of comedians who
only write on stage and they're great
and I'm envious of that so you like
everyone's got their
style I don't think there's a right or a
wrong way to do it but for me personally
yeah like I hate typing I just don't
like it
I just I'm not something I'm bad at it
my girlfriend actually types in a way
where I think she's [ __ ] with me I'm
like you know there's no way you're
actually good writing words oh you are
impressive you know I'm a little slower
but I just like I do tell you a variety
- I will just and my you know OCD having
OCD and being a scatterbrain as I am
it's hard for me to focus when I'm just
like walking around or you know like I
have a pen to page to put it to then I
can do that and then after I've done
that then I can walk and because I've
seen it on paper I'm a little more
focused when I'm just walking around
between gigs or just taking the units
it's a process the process to me like
the way I perform is always shifting and
changing mm-hmm so it works for me but
like it doesn't work for everyone well
before we get out of here you've been
very generous with your time and insight
I've been rambling I think I've been
shouting at you for the past listen to
me if there's so many different planes
to exist on comedy doesn't just have to
be in the goddamn orgy to be in a river
yeah you could be a horse or you could
be an owl but comedy is like a headline
now like you think louis c.k comes back
and performs and then it's like breaking
news like what is your opinion on that
whole situation
I mean like that's you know that's gonna
be what its gonna be on me like that's I
I know I don't think anyone in their
[ __ ] right mind agrees with what
Louis did but at the same time like what
point does casting him out and not
letting him back what do we learn from
that
mm-hmm like then he just becomes this
guy that like think about the fact that
like they're furfrou for those of us who
were like I mean that was wrong there's
a whole [ __ ] world of people out
there who are like he didn't do [ __ ]
wrong and they've all got podcasts and
they've all got you know internet like
you know the Alex Jones of the run and I
Louie could easily be invited back into
that world or into that world to begin
and then he becomes therefore you know I
mean like and then it's like oh now he's
over there and they're encouraging him
to [ __ ] on everything not saying he
would do that but like why not let him
back to hear what he has to say right
that's how we learn
like he should get back and [ __ ] T he
has to talk about this he has to talk
about it
and he in my opinion he has to talk
about it specifically specifically why
it was wrong and what he's done to get
better and how other how men should
[ __ ] treat women like he they she
that you shouldn't do that sort of thing
and he should talk about that and make
it funny like he will mm-hm and then
[ __ ] maybe some kids some
fourteen-year-old who catches that HBO
special or that or hears that on a
podcast you know in the middle of the
night is like man it's really funny and
also yeah man you should be more you
should be more respectful of women's
personal space you know right like that
yeah there could be some real good that
comes of it I just don't I feel like
being like he can't come back yet that's
just come on the guys had everything
taken away from it I know those women
have also you know [ __ ] suffered
because of it and we should definitely
hear their stuff their story and all
that but also like now we should know
what this dude
what he was thinking and how he's peeled
do you know if he talked do you know any
comedians that were there that night
then yeah if he talked about those kind
of things
oh he didn't do anything but also from
well you know the guy hasn't done
stand-up in almost a year
oh my god let him let him get his
imagine that long yeah [ __ ] sea legs
back so that he can talk about it
properly yeah to get the car get
confidence on stage again like it's a
muscle you got to work a lot of
controversial thing again I mean like
it's also there's so many I mean it's
[ __ ] ridiculous what people want to
go after you know what I mean like and
and and at the end of the day like like
I I think there's a difference between
like to me it's all about the joke
itself like if you make a [ __ ]
offensive joke I'm more about like well
that's if it's cheap shitty and stupid
then I'm not on board but I mean you
tackle a topic that can be a deemed
offensive but then have some creative
well written spin on it that leads to an
actual angle or opinion that is funny
that's like no that lemon don't go at
that do that we should all be trying to
do that we should all be trying to make
the darkest things about the human
condition funny so that we can all kind
of accept it a little more and move past
it and develop the strength to overcome
it when faced with it because we were
able to laugh at it at some point but
laugh at it for real in a way that's not
like haha [ __ ] you more like laugh with
it and then rise above it yeah that's
like on your website to like expose the
flaws or laugh at our flaws humans what
does it say it's the takes expose the
beauty of human flaw yeah I mean yeah I
guess if every comedian has like a
mission statement mine is to be like
look how [ __ ] up and ridiculous I am
and I'm okay with it
and if you feel [ __ ] up and ridiculous
about who you are you could be you know
you can do yeah you could be okay - I
think I'm okay I'm mostly okay you'd be
better than me this is a great dude
thank you so much for doing this with me
yeah before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
you go on my what is this it'll be I'll
pray in a week I'll release them every
Monday so pray the next month oh um you
go on my website which is me Sean Patton
mes EAN PT one.com I am touring non-stop
for the remainder of 2018 check come no
show I would like to see forget that
there's a camera there this or something
yeah right there yeah come on the show
and I'm working on this new hour that
I'm filming hopefully by the end of this
year we'll see great but like yeah come
out do a show come talk with me
and don't talk with me during the show
do it wait till after the show yeah just
come just right now I'm just touring
constantly so just come out come to a
show I'd love to see you I'm all over
the [ __ ] map so let's do it is that
the is that the hour you did it Edinboro
that's about like bedwetting and OCD no
I did that I did
that our and n bara that was fun they
taped if that's what you want your
question about that I was doing
specifically for that Edinburgh fest oh
okay I know my hours like some of the
bits from that but it's another
different hour it's evolved yeah because
you had said you didn't want to do an
hour until you cuz you want you had done
an hour yet cuz you want to be like
different from just the standard
stand-up special she's got a couple aces
in the hole one I just want it to be
more me at that was my whole thing was
like I felt before
Edinburgh any our special I had just
felt too much like an hour special right
just felt like [ __ ] what is unique about
me I'm in this stuff mm-hmm so I did the
one-person show at Edinburgh which you I
love that experience but you learn a lot
doing a one-person show and from there
it was like no this is now evolved it's
more like that show is dissolved into me
more and into my what I do on stage now
so it's almost like that one-person show
made everything else I do in my opinion
I mean I got better at it because of
that show I would imagine that make
sense yeah that's like that show was
like I was 26 nights in a row doing it
every single night and you had to be
more scripted there deserve a reviewers
coming in and that festival lives and
dies by the reviews but then after was
all said and done it was like man I just
can I just feel better as a performer
and now I want to take what I learned
from doing this show and and the
material from the show and just infuse
it into my standup I look forward to
seeing that man yeah man it's a thank
you I thank you thank you thanks for
your time buddy Sean Patton
breath verse hey yeah thanks man thank
you hot breath verse that was Sean
Patton
I'm your host Joel BIOS thank you for
listening we're on youtube itunes
spotify stitcher joel barish calm be
calm is my schedule all that jazz I love
you so much thank you to most unique
astir keep taking care of this
production here most unique is calm my
wife thank you and BIOS for making the
theme song for this song for this song I
don't know just play the song we're out
here every Monday your weekly guide to
comedy mastery peace